قال الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم الرئيسي ان
طهران ستوجه لامريكا وحلفائها صفعه قويه
تجعلها تندم على محاولاتها بث الفتنه في
ايران حسب تعبيره واضاف ان من وصفه بالعدو
سعى الى عزل ايران وتقيد علاقاتها في
المنطقه والعالم محاولا تكرار سيناريوهات
جربها في دول اخرى على حديث تعبيره
وحلفائها اننا سنواجه لها صفعه قويه
تجعلها تندم على محاولاتها نشر الفتن في
ايران الاعداء يشعرون بالسلطه تجاه بلادنا
لما حققتهم من تطور في المجالات العسكريه
والتكنولوجيه وزياده الانتاج صادراتنا
النفطيه وغير النفطيه لم تتوقف اعتقد
العدو ان بامكانه عزل ايران وتقييد
علاقاتها في المنطقه والعالم لكنه فشل
اراد العدو تكرار سيناريو جربه في دول
اخرى لكنه واجه اراده شعبنا الفولديه
واحبطنا مؤامراته وحساباته الخاطئه